ça y est mesdames et messieurs le moment
est venu comme de participer activement
à la purge and mail pendant cette nuit
tout crémeux sera légal tous les
aéroports d'amérique sont en
effervescence
des hordes de voyageurs étrangers
viennent participer cette année à la
purge de la liberté sur m tous les
appels du touriste du meurtre pour la
première fois cette nuit où tout crime
était remis prend une envergure
internationale où vivent leurs gardes
alors que le compte à rebours du début
de la purger lancer un mouvement
réclamant la fin de ce rendez vous
annuel prend de plus en plus
d'importance sénatrice d'opposition sur
lebron a scandalisé les conservateurs en
demandant l'abolition de la purge
c'est une nuit qui stigmatisent notre
pays nous devons y mettre un terme
alors que la purge la plus contestée de
l'histoire approche beaucoup craignent
pour la sécurité de la c'est la crise
qui sème la discorde
il est grand temps de s'occuper de cette
sénatrice ok c'est parti
c'est le commencement de la purge
annuelle dès que retentira la serène
tout crime y compris celui d'homicides
sera légale durant les douze heures qui
suivront la seule chance que j'ai de
gagner c'est de prendre tous les risques
un boulot c'est d'éliminer les risques
et vous garder en vie cette année nous
profiterons de la purge pour faire le
grand ménage de printemps
quelqu'un nous a trahis ici pour vous
on est seul ils veulent votre mort
il ya plein de tarés dans les rues on a
plus qu un des papas survivants qu'est
ce que vous faites dehors la nuit de la
burj sénatrice
on a tenté de m'assassiner montrer
une traque
agrément
je dois tout faire pour que vous sur
vivier
il arrive à temps
purger ces êtres américain
oui
les crises
et tu as kenya
we need you get le 12 mai
djiby américaine